[Música]
e
y ahora que ya lo tengo entonces cuando
yo y ese momento yo sabía que quería ir
a la universidad y tuve el privilegio de
poder hacer de una familia que me apoyó
en esa idea sin embargo no teníamos
claro y hace 20 años cuando me tocó
tomar esa decisión
sabía privadamente equivales que quería
una carrera de letras pero nada más mi
familia pensaba que no podía hacer nada
así que me parte en el primer año en la
universidad y materias y me interesé por
las autoridades y particular por el
apertura de la mística
algunos cursos de especialización y
buenas notas
entonces es conversar con profesores y
hubo una conversación que para mí
fui a conversar y el profesor era el
maestro luis jaime cisneros siempre me
ha enseñado música y la ciudad su
oficina y escucho todas mis dudas
existenciales con una paciencia enorme
ya te olvidaré esa conversación recuerda
como si fuera ayer cuando el profesor si
menos me dijo en señorita correcto
ya sabemos lo que no va a hacer usted
tiene que encontrar lo que quiere ciento
y eso para mí fue un poco para salir si
bien el accidente hizo nada por empresa
nunca y es así como vientos tres alas
inicios sociales y recursos de cátodos
de tipo declara antropología en la
ciencia social de ciudad la cultura y en
un momento crítico que me trataba de ser
mi familia que debe estudiar se aproxima
que tenía que pasar la facultad que se
llama porque definir esta semana
entonces fuimos la noticia y me
recibieron o cara de preocupación
comunes
a vivir la más directa de todos una
buena teresa que me dijo me diga si
antes cuando tú querías ser literal no
me imaginaba que iba a ser escritora
ahora que estoy en esa cosa rara y la
topología no tengo idea qué vas a hacer
entonces empecé básicamente a continuar
mi carrera y este lugar porque tenía mi
familia y yo tuve ese momento la puerta
predecible porque no es tan sencillo
imaginarnos lo que hace un científico
social no es una profesión al parecer de
otras que tengamos claramente la mente
15 esta meta es está rico y por eso los
invito en este momento a imaginar cuando
yo les dije ustedes me imaginé cierren
sus ojitos un ratito y piense un
científico una científica que ver
levanten la mano 4 - sinceramente
cuando nosotros pensamos en ciencia lo
que normalmente viene a nuestra mente es
lo que vamos encontrar se quita
ingresamos a hugo yasky pero científico
científica vamos a saber vamos a ver
imágenes de laboratorios equipos
sofisticados de investigadores
haciendo
experimentos que son fundamentadas y
ciertamente las ciencias básicas las
ingenierías de biología han sido
fundamentales importantes para el
progreso humano para el avance
tecnológico pero la ciencia y rivas la
ciencia también tiene más especialidades
tiene a las humanidades y tienen las
ciencias sociales y ciencias sociales
como exactamente eso bueno yo termino
donde se agrupan diferentes disciplinas
la antropología que no que yo estuviera
sociología economía ciencia política
entre otros
exactamente aquí tenemos complicado
porque tenemos que definir algo muy
complicado pero si tuviéramos que hacer
una decisión algo concreto diríamos que
como sus nombres lo señala son las
ciencias que se dedican a estudiar el
funcionamiento de la sociedad la forma
cómo las personas interactúan entre
nosotros interactuamos con el entorno
estudiar la cultura nuestra relación con
el ambiente
y por eso los temas que puede trabajar
los científicos el universo puede pasar
por ejemplo desde la pobreza cambio
climático desde la reforma política de
la diversidad mundial desde la educación
a la salud tema que a todos nosotros sus
intereses de los productos como
ciudadanos por eso mismo que los temas
son tan diversos expertos científicos
sociales nos vamos a encontrar también
en lugares diferentes en el estado en
las empresas en la academia es el mundo
de donde yo a mí
como investigan los científicos sociales
como produce el conocimiento
digamos de nuestro laboratorio es el
mundo y cada ciencia social tiene su
perdiz la que yo la que yo estudié en
antropología trabaja mucho con la
obesidad la investigación cuantitativa
que es la investigación que genera
conocimientos sobre la base de la
relación con las personas la relación
con la gente el contario trabajamos como
observaciones entrevistas y tenemos este
concepto que se llama trabajo de campo
que son básicamente en inversiones que
uno hace en la realidad que estuviesen
realidad pues región
pues en dos ministerios pues se necesita
pública o hacer tu barrio que puede ser
pudiste y para nosotros el trabajo de
campo es algo muy importante no
solamente porque en de donde los
voluntarios para publicar nuestros
libros y nuestros artículos
es importante porque en el camino
personal y para un momento muy especial
y que aparcó mucho la persona que es hoy
en día fuego no me tocó viajar a la
comunidad
cuando hice mi licenciatura
para mí es una experiencia que yo con
mucho asistente primero porque me moría
de miedo la verdad de la milanesa tenía
que estar allí estuve cerca de seis
meses vive con la comunidad lo que
estaba investigando de arequipa con una
serie de proyectos vinculados al
desarrollo tecnológico que ha llegado a
esta comunidad pero era la primera
víctima de la selva una chica irradiado
no tenía mayor mayor conocimiento y
estaba solo
no recuerdo que un asesor es decir la
doctora para acompañar esta tesis y
todavía pero para mi experiencia fue
especialmente impactante porque no
solamente fue aquella que a través de la
cual yo obtuve el título profesional que
obviamente es algo importante sino
porque son experiencias que marcó mi
propósito profesional y es ahí donde yo
me di cuenta que si alguna experiencia
con la axencia social era contribuir a
que las políticas de desarrollo las
políticas públicas
y naciones que buscan superar la
desigualdad y la pobreza tengan un mejor
cable a tierra que sean responsivas al
contexto y respondan a la diversidad
cultural responda a las personas con las
cuales se quiere trabajar y bajo esa
idea y hago mi vida profesional en estos
años y como ninguna disciplina tiene la
varita mágica el santo grial sobre temas
más complejos como la pobreza y la
desigualdad es que me considero en
realidad como una persona que está
dedicada a tender puentes entre lo que
es mi disciplina puedo ofrecer lo que
saben otras disciplinas como la economía
las políticas públicas de innovación que
están también interesadas que la lucha
contra la pobreza y el cierre de las
desigualdades
estoy aquí porque cuando primero también
para decirles que con el paso del tiempo
los convenientes precios profesionales
fatalmente descubriendo más sobre sí
mismo y también me di cuenta que en ese
camino importante transmitir la
importancia de aprender de la gente
porque es algo que crea mucho en villach
a veces pensamos que los científicos
estamos en una torre de marfil pero
estas son las experiencias que ahorro
realmente me hacen entender que más lo
que más tienen o diseñar uno va a
recoger de los demás en utilizar el
propósito por el cual estoy aquí es para
compartir sus tres unidades de cuando
estoy convencida y estoy convencida que
decir los sociales hermanos pueden
ayudar a construir una sociedad mejor a
lo largo de su historia se han producido
los variables libros de artículos que
nos ayudan enfrentar los principales
retos de oportunidades para el
desarrollo del pueblo se ha ofrecido
mucha evidencia que ha ayudado a mejorar
la realidad
sin embargo yo estoy convencida de las
listas sociales son especialmente con
peces porque más allá de darnos
soluciones respuestas o números nos abre
preguntas
y todo eso pienso yo es clave porque es
lo que aprendemos cuando llegamos al
contexto antes de transformar los comer
con a tratar de entender dónde estamos
yo creo que esto es unidad muy
importante de cara
dos años
vamos a soplar las velitas de la nación
yo creo que es un momento que debe ser
una especie de sentido cuando no
solamente reiniciar porque porque como
sociedad no podemos seguir solamente
pensando el presente económico el
desarrollo institucional si es que no
nos preocupamos de construir una mejor
sociedad una sociedad más cohesionada
más comprensiva y hacer que sus
diferencias entre los puntos en común
en esta línea procesos sociales nos
pueden ayudar
muchas gracias
termina